what I your cash drawers when you go to
shun nudity before the war is fought for
several months on at this Center for
homeless men in saarbrücken in Germany
run by the Catholic charity Caritas
ralphs tools and says he's on the road
to recovery quieter in films were be my
google him for another informative you
play and be careful for sure there have
been a middle of your plane there are
four million homeless people like Ralph
in Europe and helping them is a key
priority for many MEP s as they seek to
replace an expiring program for the
needy but not Germany itself whose
government argues helping the needy is a
local responsibility nonetheless
organizations like carrot ass which
receives some EU money welcome
continuing involvement and doesn't an
hour started on a good informed us Ian
Hunter so does we are was fab and dying
in profit here as we didn't mention hard
education to hear it for without
starting forts of a few million beer at
us the traditional to a perv orden de
angered ignite Europe's most needy
number around 40 million a figure likely
to grow in view of the continuing
economic crisis many MEP s including the
author of a key report before Parliament
want to increase a new fund from the
proposed 2.5 billion euros spread over
seven years to 3.5 billion I've met many
organizations from many different
countries who tell me that they are
experiencing a and an almost huge
explosion of people turning up other
centres looking for and looking for
assistance we're looking for a 3.5
billion euro program is it sufficient no
it's probably not to deal with the
crisis but at the same time it is it's
an important tool other MEP say they
need to send a strong signal of support
to Europe citizens to three hop new haga
una cosita yeah no haga haga de la
paloma regard regu politique la
Vallecano partisan celle la vella the
Solidarity social welcome words
doubtless ins are broken there as across
Europe the breadth of demand from the
neediest is on the rise and any help is
and will be well received